my that's what the red heat is the small
folks say its color comes from the blood
egg on spill to win his crown fools
blood doesn't soak into stone no matter
how hard I try
Aegon built his castle of red rock to
remind people of the Faiz he'd roasted
his enemies in so whenever King's
Landing locked up they'd see the price
of defiance he knew the first rule of
kings only fear keeps men in line fear
and punishment a lesson he taught his
son may go when the builders finally
finished the red keep meg or executed
them all to keep its secret safe
rumor has it miles of hidden passageways
run behind the walls and under the
floors one day I'll have to find them
traitors and women work in shadows a
king has no need for secrecy
now people named Meg all the cruel but I
doubt any dared in his day his strength
was all too rare in the degenerate
Targaryen blood the simpering Baelor the
Blessed created the maiden vote to
imprison his own sisters and save
himself from carnal thorns disgusting
though I admit a prince form could be
amusing when Tommen bores me my favorite
place in the red keep
there's so many the freighters walk or
I'm ants the heads of my enemies
it's a shame flesh rot so slowly
I've almost run out of space the
dungeons are also quite nice once you
get past the first two levels a stable
for common criminals and private cells
for useful highborns how boring I know
but then you come to the black cells no
windows no torches just darkness and
whatever you hear in there with you here
we keep the greatest traitors until the
king is ready for them and with these I
often like to take my time but I've
heard rumors of an even lower hidden
level Megos favorite once a man was
taken here he never saw the Sun again
nor heard a human voice nor breathed a
breath free of agonizing pain Varys must
know the way but that overgrown girl
pretends not to maybe he fears I'll make
him a victim maybe I will
then again torture chambers are just so
private better to punish your enemies
where everyone can see and remember like
the Targaryen who forced his nephew to
watch as he fed the boys traitor mother
to a dragon Oh what I could do with a
dragon
even Ares fool as he was new to burn men
alive with an audience to spread the
terror far and wide across his kingdoms
of course I know my favorite place now
when I sit on the Iron Throne
high in the red keep all of Westeros
scuttles below me like insects waiting
for my heel to land